how come Beyonce sent you flowers when I
made that uh that formation video oh
yeah yeah [ __ ] for that I had gotten
permission from her she's like Goldie
and I just want to like make this thing
and whatever and and she sent me flowers
and people get people got mad at that
they had no idea that she had said it
was cool with her to do yeah but you
know what it really wasn't even about
that it was just like we just made this
this thing um that we were having Hawaii
and like we were so into that album and
it was before the election and we were
just like I don't know we just wanted to
make like a thing with all girls and
that was that over the summer and yeah
and I don't know I've been thinking
about this a lot lately I don't know
that this is the the venue for this but
like I've always you know I get accused
of things that are not true um and one
of those things is being racist and I
realized that I'm not racist I've always
seen scene everybody is totally equal
that's the truth you know but I wasn't
doing enough I didn't know how in
Heather how little equality there was
not just for men and women but for like
people of color too and it wasn't like I
need to be doing stuff to to make that
better like I it's not enough to just
recognize and go oh that's unfair I'm in
a position where I can like try to help
with that and so at what point did you
start to regret saying that in here as
soon as I started but did you start to
feel like you needed to be or wanted to
be socially conscious of things but
itself oh no no but I didn't you know
you start out you sonant be funny and
tell jokes and do well as a comic um no
I mean maybe like before my first hour
special I did stuff about rape um like
how if she's asleep it's it's still a no
so that was like maybe the second season
of my TV show I realize like people were
listening and and people are trying to
sort of write about me like a like a
voice for women or whatever right and uh
and I rather than like be burdened with
that I looked at it as like an
opportunity and I was like oh I can try
and say things and try and make it funny
you know I would talk
grape-like gray area rape when it's not
like you being thrown in a bush and like
you know rape I like a homeless person
but if you know the guy whatever so I
like kind of then so maybe like I don't
know you surprised ago are you surprised
at the response people have accepted
being very angry if you take one stance
the other side just hates your guts
automatically I um I was surprised by
just the things that I just see is being
illogical like it's like I want to get
it it's a couples therapy you know so
what I when I would do work with with
every town for gun safety what I'm
saying is I think that uh just people
who are severely mentally ill or are on
the terrorist watch list shouldn't or
I've been convicted of domestic abuse I
don't think those people should be able
to get guns and then you go like well
what did you hear when I just said that
and they're like I heard you wanted to
take away all guns right and you go okay
that's not that's not what I'm saying
and they're like no that is what you're
saying and because you know the NRA and
like people have they've done a good job
because it's our business of
brainwashing the people that they're
keeping captive actually of scaring them
like well the government might take your
weapons like they've never done or
whatever it's one-sided like if you're
not completely for this yeah you're
there completely again you're gonna take
that and run with it so it's so that
surprised me how much hate I got from
like that from wanting to make like you
know more sensible gun laws
people forget that you had a couple
people murdered to watching your movie
and it's like there's no more of our
personal connection when people are
watching at work you put together and
there are fans and you know that they
were killed watching something you did
yeah
like if I hadn't made that those girls
would would be alive like there's no
getting over that and just anyone who
like you know gets really annoyed with
anybody in my position that speaks up
and like you know oh Hollywood liberal
like it's like it would be a lot easier
and I would make a lot more money if I
kept my Yap shut
so I'm not saying I'm I don't want to
I'm not saying I'm a hero but what I'm
saying is
don't think that there's anything in
this for me other than than like a lot
of hatred and less money yeah the bottom
line is people have to listen like if
somebody doesn't like what you say they
can just go [ __ ] her we're [ __ ]
surprised [ __ ] there's so many other
people